good evening everybody and welcome to
the latest covered press conference i'm
delighted to be joined this evening by
brigadier joe
fosse and by jonathan van tam
the deputy chief medical officer
across this country and around the world
this evening
people are asking themselves the same
question
about where we've got to in our fight
against kovid
and that is does the progress towards a
vaccine that's been announced today mean
that we are at the beginning of the end
of our troubles so
let me set out our assessment
the fisa bioentec vaccine has been
tested on over 40 000 volunteers
and interim results suggest it is
proving 90
effective at protecting people against
the virus but we haven't yet seen
the full safety data and these findings
also
need to be peer reviewed so we've
cleared one significant hurdle
but there are several more to go before
we know the vaccine
can be used what i can say
is that if and when this vaccine is
approved
we in this country will be ready to
start using it
earlier this year the uk government
ordered 40 million
doses of the pfizer vaccine enough for
about a third of the population
since you need two doses each and that
puts us towards the front of the
international pack on a per capita
basis and i should add that we've
ordered over 300 million doses
from five other vaccine candidates
as well if the fisa vaccine passes all
the rigorous safety checks
and is proved to be effective then we
will begin
a uk-wide nhs led programme
of vaccine distribution we will decide
the order in which people are offered
the vaccine vaccination
taking account of recommendations from a
group of scientific experts
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
and their looking at a range of factors
including the different characteristics
of different types of vaccines to work
out the most effective way
to protect as many people as possible
and save as many lives
as we can we'll be sending out more
detail about that
in due course but and you know
i'm going to say this i must stress
that these are very very early days
we've talked for a long time or i have
about the distant bugle of the
scientific cavalry
coming over the brow of the hill i can
tell you that
tonight that toot of that bugle
is louder but it's still some
way off we absolutely cannot
rely on this news as a solution
and the biggest mistake we could make
now
would be to slacken our resolve
at a critical moment because on friday
sage reported that the r is above one in
england
though that doesn't take account of the
current national restrictions
alas the death figures are rising
running at an average of 300 a day sadly
double
uh where they were 24 days ago the
number of coveted patients in hospital
has risen to from just over 10 000
two weeks ago to nearly 13 000 on the
5th of november and we're heading
towards the levels of the
of the previous peak irrespective
of whether there is a vaccine on the way
or not we must continue
to do everything possible right now to
bring
the ardan and that's why we
hope and believe that mass testing
will help and our first pilot began in
liverpool on friday in partnership
with liverpool city council we've tested
thousands of people there but there's
still a lot
more to do so please if you are in
liverpool get yourself along to a
testing center there are 19 at the
moment
with more still to come and the more
people get
tested the better we can protect that
great city and drive
uh the disease done in liverpool so do
it for your friends
for your relatives for your community
and
i want to thank the fantastic support of
the the armed the army
of the people of liverpool and liverpool
city council and we're now
going further by sending out hundreds
of thousands of rapid lateral flow tests
to local authorities right across
england and also of course
to the devolved administrations we're
working
with universities to establish as soon
as possible
similar mass testing capacity for
students
up and down the country but while we're
making progress
this project is still in its infancy
and neither mass testing nor progress on
vaccines so they're both uh vital
uh arrows in our epidemiological quiver
they're both
part of the key parts of
of our fight against uh kovid at the
present time
they are no substitute for the national
restrictions the social distancing
hand hygiene and all the rest
so now it's more important
than ever to follow the rules i know
it's been
a tough first weekend of these autumn
restrictions and i'm
especially grateful to the royal
british legion and all those who worked
so hard
to ensure that no virus would stop us
yesterday from honouring the memory
of those who gave their lives for our
freedom
but we must get through this to the
second
of december when these measures expire
and
we plan to move forward with a a tiered
approach remember the basics then hands
face
space and follow the rules and that's
how together we can protect
the nhs save lives and get the virus
back in its box
that is what we will do